hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today game number
six 2016 we'll chess championship so far
five games five drawls Sergey Kelly I
can play the white pieces looking to
make something happen
different than a draw so he starts out
with the white pieces against Magnus
Carlsen pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight to f3
knight c6 this looks like all the other
games so far Bishop to b5 pawn to a6
back should bish back here to a4 knight
to f6 having a little bit of deja vu
castle on the King side Bishop to e7 if
you're curious if this is game 4
no it's just all the exact same moves
pawn to b5 pushing back here to b3
castle on the King side pawn to h3
Bishop e7 pawn to d3 and then we
actually see our first move that's
different the game number 4 and I've
been at this point the players have used
about 60 seconds of time because they're
going so fast because they've already
played this game before now usually from
white if he's playing this pawn to h3
this pond to the e3 that's kind of the
anti martial opening because sometimes
you may play pawn to c3 is the main line
and then your opponent plays pawn to d5
very sharp line from black giving up a
pawn to material a gambit here where the
pawn could take all of a sudden the
Knight takes Knight comes up here takes
that pawn a black is giving up those
central pawns for an exchange in attack
he opens up the lines with Bishop to b7
if you wanted to could take but really
that's not what he's going after but it
could take you know if the rook
recaptures bishop here to b7 it opening
up the door for some attacking lines on
the King side of whites you know
although White's up and material a lot
of players if they're playing why
especially at the top level they try to
avoid these lines and so you'll see
things instead of that pawn to c3 pawn
to h3 you'll see after Bishop to d7
you'll see pawn to d3 Magnus Carlsen
saves us a little bit and says okay
we're not gonna play the exact same game
I'll try something a little bit
different and the previous game you
played pawn to d6 and this particular
game you played pawn to d5 so playing
almost that anti are playing the
Marshall attack and an anti Marshall
opening in cardiac and immediately
responded with pawn takes on d5 Knight
takes and that up here on e5 and then
Knight to d4
so this is kind of the first I would say
somewhat tech that you could tell magnus
carlsen prepared for this he's not
spending any time on his moves on
cardiac an immediate plays Knight to c3
so there wasn't tons of time thinking
about the these moves so it looks like
cardiac can actually studied and
prepared for defense against this I
guess if you're gonna be playing tons of
that right Lopez you need to be aware of
what your opponent could do here that
over here to be for a bishop to f40 had
some other options instead of night to
our Bishop to f4 I really like ponce it
to a three put your opponent to the test
and says even if you're not even a 100%
sure what your opponent's going to do it
kind of forces their hand you don't want
them to get too much material involved
before you figure it out so this kind of
says okay you need to move your knight
capture something let's do something so
if we could say Knight takes on b3 we
capture pawn to f6 force in the knight
to move Knight comes back here to c6
I think White's gonna be in a
particularly okay position he's up upon
him it's here I'll isolated pawn in the
center of the board all in all I think
this is fine but cutting I can decided
to go and bring his Bishop out here to
f4 centralized a knight takes on b3 this
was the first move that Magna Carlsen
took more than like seven seconds in the
game it took about four minutes it's not
too long but we see the pawn recapture
here and then pawn down here to c5 and
he had some other options as well here
you could play Queen to deform pretty
aggressive line you could see Bishop to
g3 since it was being attacked we were
coming here to e8 just adding pressure
in the center of the board
94 f5 if we really want to get crazy for
Magnus Carlsen ac3 forcing one of the
these pieces to move Queen here to d5
could see the pawn captured Bishop down
here to b4 and we start to see some
fireworks I think this would have been
very entertaining to see what we see
pawn to c5 nonetheless opening up the
door more for a queen side attack from
Magnus Carlsen and the Knight to e4 and
this is kind of where cardiac can
actually started used a little bit of
time he didn't seem flustered at all
seemed like he was prepared but this was
the first time that he didn't use maybe
five to six seconds in the game pawn to
f6 for Magnus
Karlsson pon our night back here to have
the reasons it wasn't her attacked
Knight to f5 forcing the Knights move
Knight back here to g5 and then we do
see a capture that takes on d5 pawn to
h6 forcing the Knights move the knight
really only has one place to go it
doesn't want to come back here to let's
say f3 because then the bishop could
just take here and then if the pawn
takes well that's kind of back is just
Queen down here to h4 there's double
pawns on the F file a lot of things are
under attack that bishop the pawn things
get very bad for whites here if he takes
with his queen
okay well then all of a sudden the
knight comes down takes on c2 gets that
material back but now he has a very
strong attack attacking both of these
rooks right here so if we look at where
the knight can really move to that's
kind of it other than that it's gonna be
taken immediately so it comes here to e6
attacking both the Queen and the rook it
really madness Carlsen only has one move
and that's Queen to d5 anything else
really is somewhat bad and now that I
can't really take here on at faith
because he would really decide it's
better not to get checkmated here on g2
so he decides to go and play pawn to f3
stopping that attack so I was important
to know how you're blocking because
instead of f3 if he tried Queen f3 per
se then all of a sudden the Queen takes
the pawn takes in as we said before a
knight down here to see two gets a
little bit tricky even if the knight
takes on FA it's still kind of bad that
rook over here to f8 still attacking
both of these rooks right here not going
to go very well for white so instead
decides to block correctly pawn to f3
rook to e8 just attacking the center of
the board especially putting pressure on
the Knights here rook appear to e5 so
cardiac and decides to play a little bit
more aggressive and start to attack in
the center of the board Queen back here
to a d6 a c3 forcing the knight to move
this comes over here to be six and says
okay I'm gonna go ahead and take
material we can start to exchange on
board I'm gonna take your knight
Sergei County I can says I'm gonna take
your rook first we can start to see some
exchange on board and after the pawns
take rook over here to c1
trying to control this open file here on
the C file
rook to c8 we do see exchange on board
both sides seem very very okay with
exchange of material because they are
moving at a blistering pace here Queen
to e1 they're not just getting into any
crazy positions which I think it's
somewhat disappointing in game six
but alas here we are Queen to d7 King up
here to h2 because instead of you know
this Queen here on e one is attacking
this pawn here so we could have tried
something Queen to c5 protecting this
pawn check instead he decides to go and
play the Queen to d7 hey if you want to
take my own material here I'm gonna take
your material here on d3 we can exchange
so after Queen to d7 King up here to h2
pawn to a5 Queens this to e3 Bishop down
here d5 Queen up here to b6 both sides
just say hey if you want to go ahead and
take a material here on b3 that's fine
I'll take material back we do start to
actually see some of that exchange Queen
takes here on a5 Queen down here to d3
after the Queen takes on b4 Bishop to e6
they decide to go ahead and draw the
game not a ton of material left to
really do too much especially with the
opposite color bishops it's gonna be
fairly Josh the rest of the way
32 moves from each player Magnus Carlsen
only used about 30 ish minutes in the
game cardiac in a little bit more played
about an hour so it's all very very
quick game nothing too crazy it almost
seemed like Magnus Carlsen came out and
said I'm gonna try something a little
bit different we haven't seen so far
cardiac and responded with hey I've done
my preparation for this we're not gonna
get any crazy situations that I'm not
familiar with Magnus Carlsen decided to
back off a little bit and said okay you
are up upon the material if you're not
gonna fall for any of this I'm not gonna
do anything too crazy let's exchange the
material let's get to move 30 where I
move 32 right now and then we'll just go
ahead and have a drawl get to the
weekend that's what I kind of think
happened but game number six we do have
a drawl six draws in a six game so we do
have a break tomorrow and then we come
back Saturday Academy I can actually
will be playing the white pieces again
so that
switch magnus carlsen started in game
one he will also be playing the white
pieces in game 12 if it does get to that
point so cardiac in game seven in two
days so hopefully you guys are enjoying
this tournament so far hopefully we get
some wins from someone maybe a little
more complicated positions as well but
thanks for watching I'll see you on the
next video